hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the last stand - now this
was popularly demanded after the first
game and honestly I don't remember
playing the second last stand very much
I played the crap out of the first one
that's it it's over safe at last he's
infected o mundo bah of course something
had to go horribly wrong why couldn't
you just been a peaceful experience
where we all get to go home and be happy
no okay 40 days something is still
controlling me it's been a month back at
square one the crash still haunts me
they're still everywhere radio broadcast
said today that their steel ceiling off
the mainland forty days until the last
boats and aircraft leave gotta make it
to Union City okay and there's one more
game in this series after this called
getting started way too early here you
guys are much more zippy than the last
batch hey hey Poochie Poochie Poochie
alright another newsman over there
stop doing that Watson ready see I
really don't remember planes
I do remember playing Union City but I
do not remember playing this one very
much well we're gonna pretty sure the
strategy is gonna be the same a lot of
exploration a lot of time management
proper oh my goodness oh wow the big
house search - oh that's a much better
way to do it all this that's way better
okay so that's good so I'm assuming this
means that there's a high possibility
that there's going to be guns and
weapons in these places which means that
I'm gonna have to manage my time a bit
better is there any place that's gonna
take to time there is not so I'm gonna
scratch that I'm gonna go to the
supermarket ooh
no I'm not is there anything that's five
okay and then go to the old house which
has a question mark on it so that should
be good because my barricade should
probably be okay alright I'm in Glendale
- I used to live in Glendale okay found
a chainsaw which is gonna be good enough
for two days of travel that's
interesting
I'm not entirely sure what that means
set up trap I don't have any of those
but I got a chain oh so oh and I could
sign my survivors weapons finally do I
have a journal I don't know if I read my
journal
how do I switch my weapons here you want
some of this I know that the chainsaw is
highly effective from the last time that
I had a chainsaw and it dismembered a
great Nissan boats I don't want any Girl
Scout ko my goodness is not going well
I should've gotten a better weapon I
should have been shooting him with my
gun that would have been a much better
idea of my time management okay so I
need to search and also I need to repair
quite a bit because I'm not doing too
good okay good enough for me let's do
this everybody at home
I wonder if it's randomized or if it's
just gonna be oh gosh
oh good lordy goosh Oh No what about all
the fancy words that I want to say to
everybody alright I'm just gonna start
file or [ __ ] get back get back
why did the last round do so bad for me
maybe because me am stand with chainsaw
when zombo's are coming into what we're
affected by bullets than what I'm
pumping out of them okay this is going
much better oh I should have not used my
chains on the last round hey it's a
zombie apocalypse there's plenty of time
for mistakes I'm sure it won't be costly
for me in the long run in half to play
the entire game okay there we go okay
done with that now we just need to make
our way - okay quick stop houses more
houses another one park storage good
enough for me if I can find a survivor
that'd be delightful oh my god 3:57 gas
cylinder bear trap and a survivor hey
can I give him yes I'd like that okay so
I give that to me and then I give this
to one of the survivors so they actually
have a gun and then I can set up um if I
set them down am I gonna lose them
forever because I'm gonna save this for
when things get dicey but how would I
know when things would get dicey until
they already are upon me oh I got a 3-2
shots who kills who skills bang boom
sure is nice have a known survivor
little buddy to help me out that means
that I can give them better weapons if I
ever find them that's a much better
upgrade system than the random crap that
they had in the first game back read
and/or saw The Walking Dead
taro Carl right taeho supplies gathered
well that did exactly dick diddly for me
how he's supposed to be able to do what
I'm supposed to do and why don't I have
anything to learn my thoughts alright
whatever let's do this bang bang it's
gonna start fired wildly at least they
come through a single doorway makes a
little bit easier to carnal things down
damn it what could remember the name
brick cuz it's a southern guy played by
a British man I'm gonna work on left
British accent take some British rolls
I'm gonna be the next time Lord that'll
show them for taking all our southern
places ok travel to a new location I
finally have enough good I want to get
out of this hellhole Soho Leesburg
Whistler's okay so clays burg has a more
population equals more event earth
everything so it'd be more of a risk
going to clays burg but that means I
might get more stuff but if I go to
whistlers Grove I can go straight to
Jonestown if I go to clays burg I'd
probably have to strip through Aspen
wood the exclusion zone that doesn't
sound good
so if I go to whistlers I'm gonna go to
whistlers because one it's gonna be a
little easy for me for before zombie
wise and OH
whistlers Grove basements not a fan but
it's a necessity at the moment built a
crude barricade upstairs to hold them
off tonight should do the trick don't
have much time or energy to build
anything substantial best bet is to find
what I can to keep moving towards Union
City do exactly that so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna snag up all the smaller
houses because that way I can
a lot more things Medical Center indeed
in the time that I have I don't know if
it's actually gonna help because of the
three hours versus the four hours of
fighting things but I got another
survivor that's good
can I give him a chain sir can he can he
take this please
food god damn it no I guess I could give
them and then take the chainsaw but
something tells me that wouldn't be good
for me so he's gonna skip a stand there
and punch him punch him right in their
gonads oh he does have a gun good I
thought he would have been totally
utterly useless at least it's gonna be
mean I'm gonna be doing a little bit
better
oh is that a match at hey are you gonna
give that to me when you're done I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to use them a
chat a but something tells me I don't
you oh god no that's the opposite of
good get him out here Dolph your ugly
face sorry I don't mean to be judgmental
against the zombies that are against me
but I just want you dead why do I not
have the chainsaw on my equip bar did I
not put that on so many promises okay
guess we're good now cheese sums
Christmas [ __ ] oh boy that was not okay
whoa we're boned oh boy alright I'm
gonna I'm gonna hold fast that we're
gonna find something [ __ ] we found
nothing and we prepared very little yeah
so this is where things get dicey zama
to use my tricks with those there put
these I'm just gonna use the bear traps
because that's probably gonna be ideal
and then we're gonna get through this
because we're survivors and I'm not
gonna die done this hellhole why did the
trap not work what thank you
my goodness gracious suited to Jack
doodlee and I know my Jack doodlee I
mean that wasn't marginally better than
the last time but why did it that's a
good question oh we can travel doin
little little of what a little new
location thank goodness no we can't make
it to Jones sound I gotta make it to
Jonestown I need one more goddamn thing
what a load of ass alright fine we're
gonna search I wonder if it is
randomizer if it actually is very very
not randomized oh this one looks good
I'll take that give me something good I
found nothing about another survivor I
guess that's okay but I got another
supply which means that I will be able
to make it to all the way to Jonestown
hopefully fast good I think we got
enough to go to Jonestown that should be
good I'm gonna make it there in record
time
alright Jonestown Oh
alright you know what screw it why
doesn't it say how many I need to go be
able to go to Jonestown the road leads
there it do won't would be the point of
going back to Glendale and I'm gonna
spend one more one more day searching
these gosh-darn houses and we're gonna
get out of here and if we don't we're
freakin bone around cuz I ain't putting
down any more yes I found my bear traps
get out of my face diary I need you I
found a Schuster what is this what is
this crap thank you
I think okay cool we found that little
bug there don't mind that no big deal
alright I don't know if this is gonna be
better for me but I did find
okay we should be fine this should be
good but just in case it's not I'm gonna
put these here yeah that's the stuff I
think probably here we go choose just
ignore that shoots gun incoming that's
right that's right that's right
crap control baby no one's getting
through this dog that was not a good
night not a good day night oh it's not
good but we did find seven supplies if
that's not enough to get - god damnit
freak Jonestown you know what freaky you
Jonestown I thought I could have gotten
to you at least I got more supplies a
load of ass at least I got a new
barricade in this place even though I
can't read the goddamn diary what is
with this game there we go
haven't heard anything on the radio from
home why have you got to be a dick
middle of nowhere haven't heard it but I
got a hunting rifle and I know that's
good haven't heard anything more on the
radio about the evacuation can only hope
they stick to their time frame don't
like my chances of finding much here
that's to get what I can to keep moving
Union City or bust
you got that god damn it I get it I'm
gonna find some chasm this is broken out
the boat so I'm gonna try the shot just
saw no I'm gonna try the hunting rifle
I'm gonna get rid of that
give that to you gonna give this
sawed-off to that guy and we're gonna
give the normal to the you and then I'm
gonna stick with a hunting rifle and
this is gonna be good we got everything
we need here so we can probably keep
moving right to Jonestown oh yeah this
is my old jam oh this is my jam it with
your bad self get down with your dead
self Oh double kill
now that we got the shoes Gunners
they're doing way more they're doing way
more damage
this is incredibly better Oh with well
acquit survivors we M do much good at
least they're not dying nearly as much
on the searches that what happened last
week airs bang come on you there we go
oh thank goodness for good survivors
thank not goodness for my daddy but
thank goodness for everything else
involved it's not me oh no oh God he was
important he just got in the face holy
crap I didn't know that could be a thing
I find a known that I would have gone
for the guys with the weapons were here
earlier that was not okay we're out in
the middle of nowhere
Oh God was that just a factor of the
location or was that something else can
I at least go somewhere else yes I can
go to Jonestown finally yes go to
Jonestown we lost a dude but that's okay
I guess I go I'm not in the middle of no
that all goddamnit that was it's not
gonna give it's not not gonna give me
what I need but I got an A K so that's
cool I'm gonna try that
instead of what I had before I'm gonna
give you the shotgun I'm gonna give you
the hunting rifle okay I'm gonna give
you the sawn-off I don't even know if
it's gonna be any better but I got a
freakin a K so it should be
garbage the a.k shoots a gigantic why is
that you have got to be gobbling my
nards on this [ __ ] you've got to be
snarf in mob loves on this a Satori got
it good and I'm gonna be accurate when I
shoot them at least it doesn't make me
go back to the beginning gosh well those
were a waste is there weren't enough
people to take advantage of them god
damn it there we go now we're getting it
now that we've survived the initial
onslaught and we don't have a stupid 8k
that doesn't have jack doodlee we can
actually get some damage done I imagine
the vak is a much better weapon in the
hands of late your your AI buddies as
opposed to anything that you got going
on can he just I wish I was aiming right
for his head
not about where you hit it's about the
wine that you get maybe sometimes those
guys has grown up with an accent you
can't do nothing about it
oh man this is getting rough I don't
know how we're gonna manage we're doing
okay so we just need to ooh that's gonna
be dicey we got to work on the barricade
don't we yeah we gotta we're gonna die
if we don't we got to work on that
barricade we got to work on the
barricade baby okay we found an m4a1 and
a new survivor and the gas cylinder and
we were paired up pretty good so we're
gonna lay these at bad boys out right at
the end there I'm going to try to be
good about it but the m4a1 in the other
survivors hands and hopefully this is
gonna be better or it's probably not
hard cuz just never worked out for me
haha
Oh save some of that a little of that
jerk wads bags porpoise pork what a lot
of dunk estroux yep no no no you don't
got that one had a weapon man sprinters
with the weapon thing
in there it better not do that whereas
spritzers come up with a weapon and a
bunch like that oh no yeah thank you you
saved your own skin
thank you I'm sure it only shoots so
much I'll miss thank you Oh none of them
how about none of them okay we did
better than the last round surprisingly
I don't know how but we did okay oh god
we didn't find enough supplies okay we
gotta go ooh we got a surge yeah we'll
get this to apartment that leaves us two
hours two and now that'll fix right up I
don't think I was looking properly at
the number of points per hour last time
go supplies B oh nothing a whole lot of
nothing damn it
oh boy I don't want to be here much
longer we're not doing well weapons
weapons weapons weapons weapons get out
of the way big guys weapons weapons
weapons weapons weapons we're gonna web
less crappy weapons no okay but that guy
was going for it ah he was a goner
hey because the barricade is so bad and
the other one just didn't work no no no
all right in the face stop stop stop and
I know that this probably if I were to
look back and try to strategize is
probably very specific locations to
search because I don't believe it's
entirely randomized it's probably like
carefully placed and carefully assigned
so there's only certain places somewhere
but if you if you don't get if you lose
those survivors it really bones you over
because this is just brutal it's brutal
my goodness
now why god damn it no supplies Frick a
duck and grenades sound cool I'll try
those that'll be nice the chainsaws not
nearly as powerful as it used to be this
is not gonna go well for me oh well here
we go toss grenades why don't we why did
that do what is this do it what's not
going work I'm throwing it why
I mean CAI actually now I see it
it's not exactly it's kind of it's doing
okay oh no oh no I just have my grenades
[ __ ] nope okay if I hadn't have spent
so much time in that one town it'd
probably want to gone better for me
because I spent so much time looking in
a town that was not didn't have the
potential for stuff I'm gonna restart
because I'm gonna get back to the point
where I was I'm gonna read that one
journal entry that didn't work this is
what happened last time good because I
think the game bugged out a little bit
and also play screwed me over a little
bit so I'll be right back I'm not making
excuses even though I totally am making
excuses there we go
no yeah that's right back off lady back
off these are my boys me and my boys are
gonna stick around for a while
we ain't gonna stop our rolls
ciao restart the game I'm gonna I'm
gonna get better it's not gonna bother
me over that with a double Cal on my
boys to a.k.a km4 and then lots of
bullets are going down and we're gonna
put down the rest of our traps here not
in a line I remember that's apparently
bad for some reason okay that should
beat enough distance right hopefully
we'll see here we go oh boy I didn't
repair oh god I didn't repair oh god I
didn't repair I thought I repaired
oh god oh god oh god no oh no oh no oh
I'm such a goober I'm such a goober
don't run away don't run away
oh no they ran away oh no oh no I'm such
a fool I'm such a goddamn fool why
didn't I repair Oh No oh no I can't
repair now oh why why didn't I repair oh
no oh no oh no that no good wants such a
fool
there they go
oh somehow yes Oh Frick you exclusive
zone I can't even go to you Union City
baby Union City oh yes oh did I done it
oh yes Oh barely Oh barely barely barely
oh man down to the wire my own stupidity
catching me by surprise but I did it I
did it I survived it I'm the greatest
that ever played except I'm not so thank
you everybody so much for watching this
is a lot of fun I love these games even
though they're very difficult like
that's the good thing about it they're
finely tuned to where they're an
aggravating but very rewarding
experience when you win so thank you
everybody so much for watching there is
one more game in the series if you
wanted me to play it let me know in the
comments down below let me know what you
think of this game if you enjoyed it let
me know and as always I will see you in
the next week
baby learn someday